I'm thrilled i'm such a huge fan of
the marvel universe so i'm like i'm
i'm just excited to be here and
it's like the character is so
funny and pietro but he looks different because
it's evan peters and an interesting way to do it
like when kevin was telling me about it i was like
oh that sounds awesome and hilarious it's so weird
the thing that i really love so much at the end of
the journey is i think it's the first time wanda
has really accepted who she is i'm so excited now
that we've cracked open this other part of her
so that there hopefully could be more stories
to tell and so i really loved doing the show
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my video
for the Wandavision bonus episode if you didn't
know there was a bonus episode for Wandavision
is called marvel's assembled and it's basically
all the extra stuff from the Wandavision series
they'll be doing the same thing for all the other
future marvel disney plus series so they'll do one
for falcon and winter soldier they'll do one for
loki and all the other ones in the future there's
a whole bunch of extra easter eggs and stuff
setting up her for doctor strange 2 will break
down and stuff that they revealed during it so
if you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes i'll be doing falcon and
winter soldier episodes starting next week that's
right falcon winter soldier starting next week
so just careful for spoilers from everything that
happened on Wandavision if you haven't seen those
episodes yet but i'm mostly just going to focus
on the really big stuff here so we're talking like
evan peters quicksilver character what evan peters
was saying about his future coming back and doing
more marvel projects in the mcu what elizabeth
olsen is saying about coming back for multiple
future movies and disney plus series so for
instance elizabeth olsen they're talking about how
the series just in general was meant to be more
of a jumping off point for the real version of the
scarlet witch character in the mcu as opposed to
the black widow movie where the character is dead
and she was a major avengers character but they
never really gave her her own movie before they
killed her off so the black widow movie is more
of an afterthought like a really awesome marvel
phase 2 movie given to you during marvel phase
4 for the natasha black widow to pass the baton
and the mantle to the yellana bulova version of
black widow whereas they designed the Wandavision
series to be more like an iron man 1 movie for the
true version of the scarlet witch character like
a legit origin story in a way that they didn't
fully explore her origin during avengers age of
ultron when you actually saw her origin story in
another really good comparison just like in iron
man 1 setting up the iron man character to be the
foundation for the whole marvel cinematic universe
and he would go on to become this critical piece
in all the future avengers movies elizabeth olsen
kevin feige the marvel people are saying that
that's what Wandavision does for scarlet witch
and now it makes a lot more sense when you
think about how kevin feige was saying her
character would be one of the most important
characters in the mcu during marvel phase 4.
on a story level the big reason for that is the
way they set her up with her chaos magic and
clarify how her powers work on a fundamental level
like in previous movies avengers age of ultron
captain america civil war avengers infinity war
avengers end game you see her use her abilities
but there was that evan peters quicksilver joke
about her giving people nightmares and shooting
red wiggly woos out of your hands that was the
Wandavision writers so they're making fun of
how underdeveloped her character had been in the
past like what exactly is she doing to people they
never really explore that in detail or clarify or
how powerful she really is in the way you totally
understand how iron man's powers work or how
the hulk's powers work like gamma energy makes
him stronger the matter he gets really simple
concept there's no limit to how strong he can get
is just a function of rage or when banner's
able to make a deal with his hulk persona and
they go half and half working together to become
the professor hulk so just to explain how the
marvel people are officially explaining scarlet
witch's powers now heading into doctor strange 2
her red energy is not infinity stone energy
so to speak there were always questions about
that during avengers age of voltron even during
avengers end game when she was fighting thanos
it is related to infinity stone energy which
i'll explain in a second but she is a full-blown
magic user just like doctor strange that's why
they call her a witch the scarlet witch though
is actually a title of a magical being prophesied
in the darkhold who will come have near infinite
cosmic power and they will use that power
to destroy the world now there's a whole
lot of other stuff going on with that darkhold
storyline so i'll follow up on that in a second
but when she's blasting thanos for instance or
when she's giving iron man visions in age of
ultron when she's flying or when she's controlling
people's minds using all these seemingly different
types of powers really she's doing the same thing
she's weaving spells harnessing the energy of
spells like doctor strange the difference is
where her magic comes from and how that magic
works differently from other people's magic in
the mcu like doctor strange's magic so the way
they explain magic in the mcu is that normal types
of magic like the type that doctor strange uses to
power his spells or the dark magic from dormammu's
dimension that kaecilius was using or even agatha
harkness's magic which is another different type
of magic from the dark magic or dr strange's magic
those all come with a cost magic always comes
with a cost they kind of explain that during the
doctor strange movie when he starts studying with
the ancient one it's a fundamental truth within
the marvel universe but it's also a story way that
writers use to balance power levels so that things
don't get out of control the story doesn't go off
the rails the difference with scarlet witch though
is that she uses chaos magic to power her spells
and the way that the Wandavision writers and kevin
feige the marvel people clarify this is that
chaos magic is more powerful and more dangerous
because it's magic that comes without a cost
scarlet witch is able to create new magic that
didn't exist before create new spells that didn't
exist before so whereas doctor strange has to read
all these books in the library and he's very good
at it one of his secret powers is school basically
scarlet witch doesn't need to do any of that
but that ability to create new magic is also how
she's able to alter reality her reality warping
powers the way they talk about it in the comics
same basic idea they get a little technical with
it during the Wandavision episodes where they say
she's basically taking things that already exist
and rearranging their molecules to create new
things the only time that's different is when she
creates billy and tommy because she didn't take
other people's children and just reorganize
their molecules to create two different kids
but it's in that idea the chaos magic is similar
to the energy of the infinity stones like they say
during episode four cosmic background radiation
energy that was present at the big bang the energy
of pure creation and as a result of the way chaos
magic works she doesn't need to use incantations
to weave those spells like when she's using her
abilities giving people nightmares or flying or
creating barriers or projecting energy out of her
hands she's actually weaving spells to do that but
she didn't need to learn incantation she didn't
need to read those spells and learn them out of
a book she's like the ultimate make it up as you
go along cosmic being in the mcu now but it's all
a result of her being upgraded by the infinity
stone she wasn't always that powerful that's also
part of the darkhold prophecy like she always had
chaos magic in her like when she was a little girl
she was weaving a complex hex spell without even
thinking about it that's how she was able to stop
that stark tech bomb from exploding it's just the
mind stone gave her way more bandwidth to access
that power like going from dial-up internet
to gigabit internet the bigger the spell the
more access to chaos magic that she needs so she
wouldn't have been able to create the hex when she
was a little girl before coming into contact with
the infinity stones the reason why agatha harkness
is so worried during the finale why she says this
is a bad thing her becoming the full version of
the scarlet witch goes hand in hand with that
dark hole prophecy about her destroying the world
in the idea of scarlet witch as a dark character
a villain quote unquote so to speak tayonna paris
the actress who plays monica rambeau actually
talked about that during this bonus episode
sometimes you feel like well wanda's the bad
she's the villain she has turned all of these
people's lives upside down she's the villain she's
not wrong wanda is kind of a villain during some
parts of this series but obviously they try to
provide more context for why this is happening
oh she didn't mean to do it this way at the
beginning she doesn't mean to hurt these people
but she finds out that she's basically torturing
these people and it continues on for a little
while after she learns that and when she takes off
at the end she never apologized to them the writer
said that that was intentional they wanted her to
feel like a dark anti-hero type of character and
that'll continue into the events of doctor strange
2 so now a lot of people have asked does that mean
she's going to be a backdoor loki style villain in
doctor strange 2 i think that's actually another
misdirect like there are so many misdirects and
avenues that go nowhere during Wandavision they
said that was on purpose too i just did a video
for all the deleted scenes and clarifying what
some of the hanging plot threads were like some
red herrings that were intentional red herrings
meant to mislead you with the Wandavision people
never intending on completely answering all those
questions but i don't think that she's going
to be a villain in doctor strange 2 like she
didn't maliciously kill all those people during
captain america civil war out of spite like oops
accident like the commercial for the red stain
that was what that commercial was all about early
prediction is going to be a similar situation
in doctor strange 2 is what was happening during
Wandavision with the hex where we see her reading
from the dark hold in the post-credits scene
learning about the multiverse and the fact that
she's a nexus being per the show's explainer the
nexus to all realities of the mcu the multiverse
of the mcu she'll use the dark holes knowledge
to look for billy and tommy across time space in
the multiverse other dimensions in an opening all
those doors of the multiverse so to speak really
becoming a nexus for the multiverse that's how
she'll allow the main villain to enter the mcu
reality and start wreaking real havoc and chaos
so chaos magic chaos coming to the mcu i've talked
about how cathone is the person in the comics
at least who gave scarlet witch her chaos magic
powers when she was born and he wrote the darkhold
in the wondergore mountains where it kind of seems
like wanda is right now and he's the source of all
chaos magic in marvel comics so they might be
setting up a version of his character in the mcu
but we'll see how they try to tie all these plot
threads and teasers together in doctor strange 2
but talking about the evan peters quicksilver
twist with them bringing him on to be this really
misdirect ralph boner style character in all
the interviews that evan peters has been doing
since he debuted on the series he's talked about
how he would love to come back into the mcu so
they do kind of leave the back door open for him
to return as a version of quicksilver from the
multiverse and fully pay off or fully deliver on
the idea of quicksilver from the fox x-men films
coming to the mcu and per that clip of elizabeth
olsen that i put at the beginning of this when
she says she signed on to the Wandavision series
she hoped that it would be a jumping off point for
more future marvel stories multiple scarlet witch
stories that's basically her saying that scarlet
witch will appear in other future movies in disney
plus series after doctor strange 2 like that's not
going to be the last time you see her in the mcu
right now just based on how powerful she is of
course i think she'll come back in avengers 5 when
they're ready to make that movie in a couple years
but also we have the idea of adult billy
and tommy wicken and speed coming back for
full-blown young avengers types of stories in
the future anytime they come back to the mcu
in future projects scarlet witch would also be
a logical cameo character during those stories
and of course the newer rebooted mcu version of
the x-men movies that they're currently working on
she's a huge character during all those x-men
stories it'd only be natural to include her in
some of the new x-men movies in some way as
well but she's talking about magneto easter
eggs doesn't her costume look like it's inspired
by x-men magneto's costume during those films
there's a way that they can pay that off in future
movies but everyone post all your theories in the
comments below what'll happen next though is
there's a whole bunch of new falcon and winter
soldier footage that just dropped so i'll do
a video for all that my full falcon winter
soldier episode one video will post next friday
just like normal all those videos will be on the
same schedule as all my Wandavision episodes
new episodes every single friday while you
wait for everything click here for my video on the
Wandavision alternate ending and all those deleted
scenes with evan peter's quicksilver character and
click here for that brand new falcon and winter
soldier trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!